When you write a novel, you have to engage in the process of
world-building. And you have all
these linked systems in reality.
We have a reality, of course,
but in the New York City
reality of Kim Stanley Robinson's New
York 2140—this is the cover art from
that book—and sea levels have
risen by 50 years in a very short period
of time. What does this mean if
they've gone up by 50 feet, for a city
that's on average 33 feet above sea
level? What does this mean? Well, you're
gonna have this 'super Venice,' as he
calls it, right? You've got
flooding, permanent flooding, up to about
46th Street. And what does that mean for
how people move about the city? What does
that mean in a rapidly
decarbonizing economy where you don't
have long-distance transport that's as
easy? What does that mean for food
production? Where do people get their
vegetables from? Where do people get
their produce from? What does it mean for
the governance of small scale
organizations like an apartment co-op in
New York City, right? These are the types
of consequences. You have a global change,
the effects are felt
locally, right? And you have to play out
how all these things are going to work,
right? It's a model, it's Kim
Stanley Robinson's opinion of what's
going to happen. But I don't know, I think
he's on to something in most of these
things. I know that Annalee Newitz spoke
recently about—what was she talking
about? Science needs fiction. And she had
such a fabulous example of how you have
to come to grips with the
consequences of your narrative arc.
Okay, so she's got this pirate in
the Arctic, right, who's on the internet a
lot on a shipboard. And then she's like,
"Oh god, where does she get the internet
from," right? And so she had to invent
something, a technology that
provides Internet in the Arctic.
And this is the
notion. You have to flesh out these
worlds; you're playing with complex
systems. It's actually not a huge point—I
mean, well it's an important point—
but it doesn't need to be
belabored. This is fan art
for Paolo Bacigalupi's
'The Windup Girl.' And in a
decarbonized world, supply chains are
going to be highly altered, right? Where do you get your food from?
Where's the energy to run manufacturing?
Where does that come from?
Or if you have an industrial plant that
produces the machines that
you're trying to build, where do you get
the power to run your machinery?
These are all things that come out in
'The Windup Girl.' So that's point number
one. Point number two has to do with
imagining the future and imagining
better worlds. And again there's this
terrific Mohsin Hamid quote: "Part of the
great political crisis we face in the
world today is a failure to imagine
plausible desirable futures. We are
surrounded by nostalgic visions,
violently nostalgic visions. Fiction can
imagine differently. I think this is an
enormously important idea. And I feel
like it probably resonates with anyone
who is dissatisfied, say, with the current
administration and politics in America.
We really are feeling this incredibly
violently nostalgic moment.
And typically these nostalgias are for
things that really didn't happen, or they
certainly didn't happen the way we
remember them. Memory is an
imperfect process. And so by writing
fiction, we can imagine a better world.
And I think this actually has really
important implications for the type of
fiction that we should write. And in
particular—I took all the slides out
of all the ridiculous movies that have
dealt with climate—but there are lots of
them. You don't have to think very
hard about it. And what's the
commonality of them? They're all
post-apocalyptic. We
love Mad Max and Waterworld—we didn't love Waterworld, but we loved
the idea of it.
These are post-apocalyptic
stories. And they're not better futures.
Maybe there's some heroine, you know, Katniss
Everdeen or whoever comes in
and does the heroic thing, and
that's interesting. But it's not—
we're not imagining a better world. I
think we need to do better in imagining
better worlds. And the thing is, there's
plenty of fiction that does exactly that.
So that's the good news. Now we have to
convince Hollywood and whoever makes TV shows.